this 3d printer has the ability to print
fruit and a laser device can detect the
presence of alcohol vapors in passing
cars then send a photo to police
officers waiting down the row Vsauce
Kevin here this is mine
supernumerary robotic limbs will give
you extra arms researchers at MIT are
designing them to help with tasks that
may be otherwise impossible such as
screwing in objects overhead or opening
a door while having your hands full
they're working on prototypes that can
be worn around the waist and on making
the arms intuitive to movements to
predict what the wearer needs help with
kepler-10c is a rocky begger earth that
weighs 17 times more than our planet and
this new discovery means potentially
habitable planets could be closer than
we thought
cin touch gives prosthetic hands the
ability to mimic human fingertips the
tactile sensors can distinguish between
different objects and surface textures
and the hands can also sense the
pressure needed to pick up an object
without crushing or damaging it and the
fingertips consist of a rigid core
surrounded by an elastic liquid filled
skin the Infinit Equis an
omnidirectional treadmill designed to
work with augmented and virtual
realities the user can walk in any
direction infinitely and they're hoping
to use this for applications ranging
from gaming and law-enforcement training
to physical fitness researchers at MIT
are creating a camouflage generator that
could eventually lead to digital
invisibility cloaks the algorithm
analyzes multiple photos of a scene
taken from different angles and makes a
camouflage image to cover eyesores like
electrical boxes air conditioners or
portable toilets but they still have a
ways to go in order to account for
changes in lighting the city home can
make a two hundred square foot home feel
three times bigger the transformable
gesture controlled multi-purpose unit
can become a bed a desk and a dining
table and can be easily moved doubling
the size of your living room bathroom or
kitchen but no word yet on when it'll be
available to the public this newly
discovered fish dwells in cave streams
in southern Indiana and has no eyes but
does have an anus behind its head
researchers at Rice University have
developed a method of killing or
damaging cancer cells by using gold
nanoparticles after the use of some
chemotherapy the gold nanoparticles that
target specific cancer cells are
introduced they're stored just beneath
protective outer membrane of the cancer
cell when a tiny laser is shown on the
cells since gold can't absorb the
wavelength of light it creates tiny
bubbles that explode and destroy the
cancer cell beta brand has created a
reflective button-down shirt that makes
it easier for bicyclists and pedestrians
to be seen by motorists reflective yarns
are woven into the design and the idea
is to create fashionable clothing that
can be worn during the day but safe at
night
New York City is preparing for a massive
storm by creating an 8 mile long stretch
of dikes and a 16 foot high barrier that
will have varying functions for the city
during non storm times including
aquariums parks and public art space and
a total of 920 million dollars was
recently awarded for various storm
proofing efforts this robot from Korea
can run 46 kilometers per hour and was
inspired by velociraptors so yeah the
jennie-o is a portable generator that
captures energy from your movements and
converts it into power for your
electronic devices every five hours of
just carrying the jennie-o provides an
hour of talk time and shaking the device
multiplies the rate of charging by 20
they can also be pre charged before you
leave and are kept charged by your
movements
finally octopuses of the night is an
underwater film shot by Dustin Adamson
during his night dives in the
Philippines
I'm gonna leave you with pizza making
robots and as always thanks for watching